if you take a look at the
richest people in the world you got uh
jeff bezos he's a [ __ ] idiot you know
he left his uh
you know he basically screwed up his
marriage by banging some
homewrecker you know essentially um
bill gates he doesn't wear the pants in
that relationship she does
he's still a [ __ ] beta idiot smart as
hell i mean he made a ton of money and
he created one of the biggest companies
in the world but
i wouldn't i wouldn't try to say oh you
know i'd love to have bill gates
marriage
two weeks later so bill and melinda
gates are ending their 27-year marriage
look at the two of them that's just a
screenshot there but
take a look at the body language between
the two of them right
i mean you tell me who's the more
dominant one between the two
somebody uh up here left the post who
was it
there he is devin he says yo rule zero
and friends called it
bill gates is getting divorced by
melinda one
once she wears the pants she'll
eventually take your shirt
i think it's pretty obvious who wears
the pants in that picture but you get
the point
anyway they made an announcement today
or bill gates made an announcement today
after a great deal of thought and work
on our relationship we've made a
decision enter marriage over the 27
years three incredible children blah
blah blah blah
and you know grow apart whatever okay
interesting that it's signed like this
is bill gates twitter
but it's signed melinda gates and bill
gates
telling you guys you treat her like a
celebrity and she'll treat you like a
fan
let's get that out of the screen anyway
that's not what tonight's show on
so um i thought i just dropped it in
there because i know some of you guys
uh not some but a lot of you have been
dming me and sending me stuff
on this all day today since that piece
of news came out
it gets boring after a while you know
relationships tend to have an expiry
date
at some point they're not you know
wedding vows aren't forever and ever
until death do us part anymore
a lot of guys still think they are but
it is what it is
all right let's scroll down over here uh
hey uh i've seen a lot of you guys
piling into the chat there what's up
jake gabriel yeti bar ruthless viking
yeah it's gonna go through another
boring divorce correct
it's gonna lose half maybe more doesn't
matter the guy's worth over 140 billion
dollars i think last time i checked
let me have a quick look here what's
bill gates worth bill gates
net worth 130 billion dollars
jeff bezos 201 billion dollars
holy [ __ ] man you couldn't you couldn't
spend that money a lifetime if you if
you tried hard all day long
that is a lot of cash that is bank right
there
it just you know what it just goes to
prove to you that
no amount of money can fix beta bill if
you want to fix beta you give me a call
you book a call and i'll sort you out
all right
i'll take care of you we'll get you
rocking
you